setecientos días después de su
imposición el uso de las mascarillas en
interiores en españa' ya no es
obligatorio la medida tiene excepciones
como por ejemplo dentro de centros y
servicios sanitarios y también dentro
del transporte público no así en las
estaciones como por ejemplo en esta de
atocha en el centro de la capital
española eso sí la mayoría de las
personas continúan llevando la la
noticia no ha sido recibida de la misma
manera por la ciudadanía sobre todo con
una diferencia de respuesta según las
edades pues yo lo veo bien la verdad
creo que ahora la pandemia ya está más
controlada y la verdad que creo que es
una medida que es positiva se supone que
se hace lo de acabar con las mascarillas
porque la situación epidemiológica ha
mejorado pero también es verdad que hay
gente que es más vulnerable o que tiene
inmunodeficiencia o que tiene algún
problema alguna patología y por lo tanto
pues entiendo que esa gente se proteja
con la mascarilla que es hasta ahora la
medida que tiene a mano en los comercios
o en los lugares de trabajo dependerá de
cada empresa a decidir si es obligatorio
o no y lo tendrán que decidir después de
hacer una evaluación el riesgo laboral
que suponga el no llevar la mascarilla
para los empleados hemos preguntado a
varios de ellos y la mayoría dice que
seguirá llevando la mascarilla aunque
muchos de ellos decían que su empresa no
les ha dicho si todavía sigue siendo
obligatoria algunos de ellos o la
mayoría lo hacen por seguridad personal
en la empresa es opcional nos han dado a
elegir si preferimos llevar la hora de
llevarla
y más que nada por precaución soy una
persona
nativa con problemas respiratorios y de
momento
el fin de las mascarillas en interiores
es un paso más en la estrategia del
gobierno español frente a la convivencia
con el hobbit 19 un paso que dependerá
en gran medida de decisiones personales
y de cambios de costumbres tras 2 años
incorporando el tapabocas como elemento
esencial de nuestra rutina